my new thing is not happy it's just
having that much yeah yes it's a portion
control tiny things turns out they're
the best you've ever had
that's what she said all right I'm here
on a Thursday with the one and only
Hannah Hart hello I'm okay
I need a better name for this day I
guess as of right now I'm tentatively
calling it Thursday Thursday no 30
Thursdays which means like thirst for
knowledge so it's like teaching you
something because you're thirsty for
knowledge is that what you are gonna
think when you say or so what would you
call it if it's a Thursday and it's
about giving someone a tutorial on
something in the world I would call it
Theo Craddock nope already vetoed binky
Thursday's thinking Thursday don't get
Thursday funk it Thursday [ __ ] it okay
I'll get thought about it Thursday all
about the Thursday TV show t-80 tat-tat
thought about no UTA Tate thought about
it on Thursday taint hmm take Friday Oh
figured out this week on tape Thursdays
we have a really great lesson for you
and it's all about starting over there
are a lot of reasons in your life that
you might start over today Hannah and I
have created a wonderful acronym system
for helping you start over and whatever
it is in your life that you need to
refresh start over
more like fart over there please
you deserve a drink it starts with E e
is for comes Yasim you have to be
enthusiastic about starting over
otherwise people will know how terrified
you are dogs can smell fear
it's like this is crazy so I'm just a
a fearful organism and she hates it
are you doing the Thriller dance the
second letter is a and that is for
appreciate the opportunities that you
have as a new thing in the universe and
whatever endeavor it is appreciate the
chance to take all the experiences you
have the past and remake them into a
better and brighter future Photoshop
what so we have a Photoshop boom another
third hand next is T for time it takes
time to start over
actually that's not true it takes no
time at all to of your prior life turned
away oh wait it's it you could be forced
to start over really but the process
will take you a while the next letter is
a four hour ism I defer to Hannah
altruism means doing things for others
selflessly meaning you will gain no self
interest by giving to them I don't know
why this is a purpose story I don't know
I either but I'm just worried earlier
nothing yeah more than two syllables
maybe you should investigate whether or
not you're starting over just for you
maybe eyes it all about you or is it
about make it about something yeah I'm
going to start over making about
something a is for about not ultrasurf
the next wonder is d4 dedication like we
said before it takes time to start over
to feel comfortable starting over and it
takes time to rebuild so you need to be
dedicated to that as a confucius likes
to say no matter how slowly you go don't
stop that takes dedication also Turtles
god they're so slow touch on trough
turtles a bit bad person said hey I
can't drop a totally why why do I was
there internal of the park
who let the child hold it
oh honey so hard not Alerus it was very
loud also yesterday I saw a dead
squirrel let's see if it's give this off
my chest
the next is eye for information
innovation and also yourself I mean
can't spell start over without eye
depends on what language you speak be
inspired be innovative and do it for
yourself but also others altruism gives
five about all kids book the next letter
is CV for creativity uh it means this
might vary for different people but I
always think that it is helpful to have
some sort of grounding in the creative
aspect of things sometimes you have to
get really creative when you're starting
over
yeah like so creative that you do the
exact same thing on a different channel
yeah just get creative with how you name
that channel the last letter is K or oh
geez don't forget your keys always
remember your keys wherever you are and
if you're not driving home just bring
your keys with you yeah case don't let
keys drive keys barkis black keys like I
keys oh my god the last letter is K four
keys because what's a key do it hits the
ignition not my card outside red button
am I in this button also yours is a bun
- and then - remember this acronym just
remember yeah dick I think we should
start over I don't know delicious I
didn't taste like vanilla see some nail
polish remover oh I thought it was great
right now here comes a terrible